well we did a video on the feistel
cipher and you know hopefully people
enjoyed learning about what I think is a
really cool method of encryption now i
actually wrote some code for this which
we didn't end up putting in a video just
because of time but i did put it on
github and you know people as soon as
you put things on github people go i can
contribute to this which is a great
thing and so we've added some extra
modes of operation so i thought that's
what we talked about today when you run
a cipher you don't just run it because
it's only got a certain block size so
how how do you do that if you've got a
fire that's two gigabytes but you've got
128 bit block then what do you do then
right so we're going to talk about modes
of operation we looked at the faisal
network which was which is a symmetric
cipher and it's a block cipher that
means it takes an input of a fixed size
and it outputs the same size that's how
block ciphers work where they take a
fixed block so that means that unless
your message is exactly that's length
we're going to have to do something to
try and actually use this cipher for
encryption right so day to day when
you're sending traffic over the network
the chances of it exactly being the
right size for AES block is obviously
quite slim so what is it we do so we're
gonna look at three different modes
we're going to get I guess progressively
better
I hope let's type with the rubbish one
but perhaps the most conceptually simple
and then we'll talk a little bit about
padding as well because of course you
might have two smaller message and then
we've got to think about it so the first
thing we could do is we could just naive
you say well look let's just split our
message into links of the book the right
size and then encrypt each block at a
time right now if we get to a message at
the end which is too short we could Pat
it in some way so this is called
electronic codebook mode and it kind of
harks back to when there was a little
codebook for you to flick through to get
the codes so we have our encryption
algorithm so this could be a five store
network could be AES could be something
else and this is going to encrypt using
some key and we're going to put in our
message message block one so that isn't
the whole message maybe that's just the
first block of a message
the first 128 the first 256 bits
depending on what your message is and
that's going to produce ciphertext 1 now
we can just repeat this process so we
can go message 2 and then finally
message 3 because I've got that paper
again the good thing is this is trivial
to implement right if you have a cipher
that works on
block splitting up some bytes into
blocks not very difficult
and then the encryption is also quite
straightforward this will have a
decription so we just go back up this
way so we go message one we can encrypt
it to soft x1 and then we can decrypt it
again back to message block one this
also has the advantage but it's quite
fast if you've got maybe eight cores in
your PC or even more than that you could
do multi-threaded versions of this where
you could be doing these two at the same
time and all these ones over here and so
if you're decrypting things that's going
to be quite quick and finally if you
want something in the middle of a big
file so let's say you're watching a
streaming movie and you want to jump
halfway through you can do that because
you can jump to whatever message or
ciphertext block it is that we want to
look at and then the encrypt or decrypt
it right then and there so that's quite
helpful so this is electronic codebook
or AEC be nice as that looks it's not at
all secure and it's terrible so so so
don't quit don't don't implement it I've
already done that online for you
the problem with ECB is that it gives
away just a little bit too much
information about our message right so
the key thing here is that assuming for
a minute that this block cipher is good
then if we have a message that goes into
this ciphertext we're not going to be
able to reverse that if we don't have
the key right so for now we're assuming
that the cipher itself is really really
good so that's good on its own but the
if message one a message three are the
same for instance then they're going to
do the exact same encryption and we're
going to get two identical cipher texts
one and three so blocks of our message
you're going to be identical now that
might not seem like a big deal but it
depends on the situation right if I send
you some money let's say at regular
intervals and then sometimes two of
those messages are the same they know
I've sent you the exact same amount of
money now maybe that's not a big deal
but the whole point of encryption is
that you know nothing about the
ciphertext and we've learned something
about that ciphertext there's a really
good example of this called the ECB
penguin the ECB penguin is an image
that's had the header removed and the
pixel data has been encrypted using
electronic codebook mode but the problem
is that a lot of the image is the same
and so the encryption is exactly the
same so you can see these obvious
patterns are still there and so you can
basically still see the penguin right
you've done nothing to hide it at all
really that's an obvious example but you
can imagine that same problem might rear
its head
in normal internet traffic maybe the the
HTTP web request you put in is exactly
the same every time and so someone can
learn this about your traffic that's not
a great idea we're gonna have to improve
on this what we want to do is we want to
do something a bit like this but when we
have two identical messages come in
we're going to have them come out of
something different right and it's not
clear to do that because these keys are
always exactly the same so this function
is the same so what we're going to do is
we're going to use something called
cipher block chaining or CBC mode we're
gonna take this ciphertext we're gonna
come back up here and we're going to XOR
it with our message and then we're going
to take this ciphertext and we're gonna
XOR our message now what this is doing
is linking the output of one block to
the input of the next block essentially
masking this message with some
essentially pseudo-random cipher text
and that means that if these two
messages are the same the cipher texts
are going to be different now before
anyone complains in the comments I've
left out the IV so we're going to have
an initialization vector here which is
another block of random which comes in
here and is X sort of message 1 right
this is so that if two message ones are
ever the same you don't see that that
the same ciphertext so the encryption is
fairly straightforward
we take message 1 we XOR it with some
initialization vector which is not a
secret right that just gets gets put in
on the message but it does have to be
random I mean clip that we take this we
XOR we encrypt we take the SPX on v and
we can work this way through the file
right so this fixes the issue would be
ECB mode pretty much now if message want
a message for you're the same the IV in
the ciphertext who are not going to be
the same almost certainly and so these
will be different and that's exactly
what we wanted if you encrypt your
Engram with this it will just look like
random nonsense right that's exactly
what we want
decription on this is exactly the same
as encryption basically it's just all
the down arrows and our upwards so
ciphertext 1 goes just straight through
here is ex-ored with the IV which was
sent with the message and that gets just
message 1 this also comes over here and
when this comes up it gets XOR to get
message 2 and so on there's kind of like
the exact reverse process with
decryptions instead of encryptions CBC
was for a long time quite well used it
get used occasionally now there's a few
issues with it the first is but it's
pretty slow right it's pretty slow
because we've lost that parallelism we
had before I can't now encrypt message
until I finished encrypting message to
which I can't do until I finished
encrypting message one if I'm watching a
streaming movie and I've decided the
first task pretty boring and I want to
jump through sorry you can't do that
because you've got to chug through the
decryption of everything first right on
small files that's not gonna matter but
for big files that could be a big
problem so it can't be paralysed very
well right it's that's not very helpful
the other issue is that it's got a
couple of security vulnerabilities if an
attacker messes around with ciphertext -
let's say on the network when it comes
to decrypt that's gonna impact what
happens to message block three directly
you're going to be able to flip bits
because of this XOR that's not something
you want to have happen right because
that allows the attacker way too much
control over what comes out in this
message right now if you change
ciphertext to this message - is going to
be gibberish right almost certainly
because it's not going to do it properly
but you could make interesting effects
on message block three like padding
attacks and other issues like this I
opened up with this kind of problem
so CBC mode is should we say better than
ECB but we're not it's not good enough
if this is a long string of messages or
parts then and you have a network
problem or something like that does that
mess you up for the whole thing yeah I
mean so if something happens even
accidentally to ciphertext one that's
going to totally mess up message one
it's also going to feed in and totally
mess up message two it's not going to
affect message three because that comes
from ciphertext - and ciphertext three
which theoretically wasn't messed up so
you'll lose two blocks of decryption if
a change happens on the ciphertext in
one block - fair that's totally useless
right because that we're gonna have to
resend that make that message because
that could be the most important part
who knows that could be the bit of the
movie I was trying to watch the whole
time so so yeah we you know this has a
few drawbacks and again it's slower
right we've gotta wait for these things
to finish these don't get used as much
in practice anymore right if ACB almost
never at all so I hope not training is
used for a few things but not really
what we do now is something called
counter mode right and there's slightly
more advanced exciting sounding version
Galois counter mode which is for a
different view let's talk about what
counter mode is and what the benefits it
has are what were the issues right one
is we want the messages to encrypt or
decrypt into different ciphertext right
and that is because we don't want to
divulge with two messages are the same
the next problem we have is that we
don't read we want it not to be nice and
paralyzer ball and we don't want that
weird attack where you can feel about
with ciphertex and it will affect other
blocks on the other message blocks
actually the solution is surprisingly
simple in terms of its design right we
don't have always interconnectedness
it's much easier than that what we're
going to do is we're going to have our
same three blocks so I think we may have
talked briefly about counter mode in the
crack attack well I forgot what I said
so let's decide again so we've got our
encryption algorithm this operates
exactly the same as it did before but
we're no longer encrypting our message
which is kind of confusing what do you
mean we're not encrypting the message
what we're going to do is we're going to
encrypt a counter and then we're get
that's going to produce random cipher
text which we're going to use as our key
to XOR with our message so we're
converting our block cipher into a
stream cipher so we're going to take a
nonce which is a number but it's going
to be unique to this particular
communication right and we have to use
this for a nut work for a number of
reasons in terms of security right so
we're going to have our nonce so this
could be a counter so maybe for the
first message is one and the second
messages - it's not private right but
you mustn't reuse it and then we're
going to start our counter so this is
block one so we're going to have nonce
plus one or maybe not so pended to one
or something like that you know nonce
plus two nonce plus three and that can
go on obviously for as long as you've
got enough bits in your counter we're
going to encrypt this now what that's
going to do because remember this
encryption function is very very good
and so the output appears essentially as
random noise so this is going to produce
128 or however many bits of zeros and
ones and it's going to appear pretty
random even though we just put in the
number one and the number two here and
the nonce this is going to be the same
this is going to produce some more
output as 128 and this is gonna put a
few some more output which is 128 bits
long all we need to do now is to XOR
just like with a stream cipher when we
talk about stream ciphers this is what
you do your key stream generator
generates a huge amount of this key and
then you just XOR bit by bit with the
message the exact same process we're
just not doing it in blocks so we're
going to take message 1 this is going to
come in here and be XOR and that's going
to be ciphertext
1 this is going to come in here message
to ciphertext to
message three rubies in a different
order every time
there we go ciphertext of three now this
has all of the properties we were hoping
for from what I was just talking about
so first of all because they're not the
nonce is the same but the count was
different for every block so even if
these messages are the same different
key material different ciphertext it's
parallelizable you can jump straight to
this one and decrypt it by just
trivially calculating this nonce plus
this number this is much much better it
has some four backs all right we talked
in when we talked about stream ciphers
about how they don't protect their
ciphertext because this is just X or if
I start flipping bits here as an
attacker bits are going to flip over
here so you're gonna have to have
something like a message authentication
code which we also covered in a video to
protect this but from actual encryption
point of view this is kind of exactly
what we want now a modern version of
this would be something called Galois
counter mode it's exactly the same it's
just for as we go based on the cipher
text we're calculating something called
a GMAC which is enough of these messages
of indication codes which is just going
to stick some tag material at the end of
the cipher text that just says check
against this to make sure that nothing
has been changed right it's going to
protect that from being altered all
right that's all the Galois canter mode
is doing so you'll see that the majority
of Internet traffic is AES and Galois
counter mode and it's going to operate a
lot like this the other thing about
counter mode which is quite neat is how
you decrypt it a bit like the firestore
right we don't actually need decryption
at all we just use the exact same
encryption process so let's imagine I've
sent you a message you calculate nonce
plus 1 you encrypt it don't decrypt it
you encrypt it to get the exact same key
material you XOR with ciphertext 1 and
message 1 pops out right because
remember if your ex or something twice
it undoes it it reversed itself so
actually you don't even if you've got a
an implementation of some cipher where
the decryption is different from the
encryption you don't even need to bother
implementing the decryption if you can
counter mode because it's just the
encryption that does both things so if
they're not nonce which I understand is
a number that you use once is known the
number is known yeah
what's the secret bit the key yes this
bit so this function because the good
cypher will turn this very predictable
nonce plus 1 into
unpredictable north and ones based on
this key you take the key away we can no
longer perform that function it's worth
noting that just like a stream cipher
if you ever reuse this nonce what will
happen is you've then got this issue
where these bits are going to be the
same for two different messages and we
can do things like crib dragging attacks
to trivially extract bits of message we
don't want to do that right so you have
to be when you're implementing something
like this extremely careful about not
reusing your nonce right so if you've
got like a 96 bit nonce that puts the
that puts a hard limit on the number of
message you can send before you have to
change your key on the last video
actually when I talked about the farce
of Safa I did actually implement a
feistel cipher now I want to start off
by saying but please don't use this
sci-fi Society for in production code
because I wrote it and I have not given
very much care and attention to how
securities it's a few issues but
actually the actual file store network